映画「君の名は。」を見てきました
めちゃ良かったです
思い出したらちょっと泣けてくるんですけど
あの、なんか
ハードル上がっちゃうじゃないすか
ああいうのって
なんかすごいヤバイのが出た！
みたいな
ハードルが上がって
実際どうなんだろうと思って
見に行ったら
ハードルを凄い
ちゃんと超えてきて下さって
本当に見て良かったなって思いました
皆さん是非見に行って下さい！
えっと僕ん家はですね、大分部屋は今綺麗なんですよ
この画角で、部屋がちょっと綺麗だなっていうのが、分かると思うんですけども
僕ん家にはまだちょっと汚いところがあります
それがこちら
家の地下につながる階段です
ここ基本的に土足なんで
その僕はいつも靴で歩いているんですけど
やっぱり土足だと土とかほこりとか
色んなゴミが沢山付いてて凄い汚いんですよね
そのまま掃除してももったいないと思ったんで
階段の上からめちゃくちゃ水を流せば
水で全部ウォッシュレットで流れていくわけじゃないですか
水の流れで汚れとかも全部まとめて落ちていくんじゃないかなと思ったんで
今回は家の中で滝を作ってみようと思います
もうそういう遊び半分じゃないんで
普通に掃除です
今日は掃除動画です
階段に滝を流すんですけども、どうせなら!
アバンティーズのそらちぃくんがもうすぐ家に来ます
あの子は心がもう汚れちゃってるので
そらちぃの心の汚れもついでに落としてあげようと思ったんで
そらちぃがの上ってくるので、階段の下に居た瞬間に
それに合わせて滝を流して
階段の汚れと、そらちぃの心の汚れを
洗い流してあげようかなと思っております
では行こう！
はい、というわけで　水を準備しました
多分 普通にこれで階段は綺麗になるので
あとはこの水の量で
そらちぃの心まで
洗い落とせるかがポイントになります
階段の掃除　頑張りましょう！
う･･･ぉお、あっあっあ!
貴様の汚い心を 洗い流してくれよう！
はぁっっ!?馬鹿じゃねぇの!?
ちょっ･･･水圧で開かない･･･っ
（そらちぃ：ああ…心が洗われた）
（そらちぃ：ありがとう はじめ…）
（そらちぃ：ありがとう、はじめ）
（そらちい：ありがとう、はじめありがとう、はじめありがとう、はじめありがとう、はじめ）
（そらちい：ありがとう、はじめ･･･あり…）